Lake Garda and northern Italy covers
some 370 square kilometres and is
surrounded by Alpine foothills the
northern shore boasts an enticing mix of
rugged natural beauty and picturesque
villages one of the best known is Lamoni
sugata until the late 1920s this was a
fishing village and could only be
reached by boat from Coos Rd has lived
in Lamoni for over 70 years he witnessed
the first tourist boom quando mussolini
queen tourism began here in 1932 when
Mussolini ordered the construction of
the goddess on a lakeside Road in the
1950s hotels replaced entire lemon
groves here with a diamo
county hotel it was at that time that
Lamoni Sol Garda with its narrow streets
and romantic piazzas became a favorite
vacation destination for many Europeans
especially Germans
a small Museum reminds visitors of those
days the progressive Northern European
female tourists were something of a
revelation to local young people they
don't know most of you they were much
more forward and open than we were we
boys would line up to go out with them
dance with them and get to know them and
in doing so we contributed to the
development of tourism here when the
holiday was over the women went home and
raved about us young Italian men
okano Sciuto they called us Latin lovers
Johnny is latin lover man limo Nestle
Garda is said to be the northernmost
point on earth where lemons girl
tourists can still see a few of the
remaining lemon groves these days it's
not just Latin lovers who draw visitors
to Lake gardez northern shore the winds
here make the spot a paradise for
surfers and sailors on the other side of
the lake a cable car takes visitors up
Monte Baldo each year around half a
million people visit this 30 kilometer
long mountain ridge on a good day you
can see Venice from here or take
advantage of the winds and go
paragliding for a bird's-eye view